good to see you sir you got everybody
here yeah I do
we've got a studio audience we need a
live audience not doing a live audience
you guys are be have you guys not done
that you've done that we do live
audience at the arena sure but we don't
do it in the studio that would be
nothing last ticket
well well well doesn't kgs got the curse
button right yeah I've been at the cuss
button for him okay you wouldn't need
the the not the mute button but the
blackout button because certain things
would be done we don't block that whole
screen out okay the whole thing no one
could see that so thanks for coming here
man I appreciate it I appreciate it I
couldn't like I said I couldn't stop in
Atlanta without getting as many of you
folks from NBA on TNT on this program
are you a jet or a giant fan being from
Queens I'm actually I'm one OD of rare
New Yorkers okay that could be a met and
Yankee yes and a jet engine that is I'm
the one of the rarest New York well rare
red net and Nick okay
rare would mean that there are others
who have that you think I do or do I
think
well let me tell you what who are the
only one I've never met anybody like I
grew up in Queens
so obviously Mets and Jets correct
because I used to play in Shea Stadium
so born it but I was born in Brooklyn
but I played my AAU for Riverside Church
which is in Harlem and all of my friends
and all of my and my relatives lived in
Harlem as well so that's Yankee Terrace
so that's Yankee giant's territory and
that's how I because all it's a foot
because now because you're from a time
in New York as am i where the sports
allegiances were based on the stadium in
which they played science used to play
in Yankee Stadium also before they went
to New Jersey and that's why and the
Jets and the Mets used to play together
so that's the way it was just I don't
know it's crazy there's just because
they played in the same stadium that you
had a route for the same but I spent
most of my time and in Queens being ball
I'm being living there rather and then I
spent most of my weekends in Harlem okay
so it was like you got to be both okay
yeah well that works again you're the
only one never met anybody cuz if you're
a Yankee fan you can't but hope for this
because the the ABA well I'm dr. Jay you
can't root against dr. Jay so that's
understand so dr. Jay John William since
super John William sitting and Larry
Keenan when the hell are the Knicks
gonna get good again Kenny it's funny
because my son won I actually
interviewed for the NIC job and okay so
I came back home with a bunch of NIC
paraphernalia my son I have two sons I
have two five kids total with two sons
and one is ten and one is 21 so I was
like oh I got some NIC gear for you guys
and they're like the Knicks suck like
yeah but and I thought about it in their
lifetime mm-hmm they had never seen the
Nixon as a good team in their whole life
so think about that the whole life the
kids my kids 20 21 and 10 has never seen
the Knicks as a good team that's awful
and us as New Yorkers that people are
we're in Atlanta now so they like what
the Hawks suck too so to be the Knicks
coach or front office to coach the coach
yeah why would you want to do that
because it was a New York that was one
of the big reason I think I do have
aspirations at one time to two
eventually I'm gonna leave the studio
Jay and and be part of an NBA franchise
but you know that that offer an
opportunity you know just I just felt
that there's a uniqueness that I could
bring and plus at that and this is the
current time this job that kind of
brings me relationships with players
that I didn't have probably ten years
ago so I'm gonna be like yo you got to
come help me out like you know I felt
that would have an ability to bring and
attract people as well because you know
if you're saying that we're in an era
now where you're grown children yes have
not ever seen a moment when the
NIC's have been good then we are
reaching maybe a stage where you're also
a rarity in the fact that because it's
the next because it's Madison Square
Garden I need to do that and exactly
they're running out of time but I'm
again the same person who loves the Jets
and the Giants is the same person that
thinks he could have coached the next to
a winner which now Charleston and uh and
Shaq always they every time the Knicks
are on to something they they hit me and
they're like see that could be you so
when I went easy fun eel because I went
in a few the day before I start telling
Charles and he's like well if you get
the job you'll be back in a year
[Laughter]
something that Charles would say by the
way you know he's kind of its kind of
ride you know it's got nothing to do
with you I mean if you look at they've
totally they're tanking I mean they're
tanking for Zion I mean they have you
know you could see a player is that good
enough to tank for right now you don't
think so
I just you know we've we've we've never
seen yeah we have we've seen it live
we've seen LeBron James is that kind of
athleticism yes and physicality but and
we've seen Charles Barkley but you know
we haven't seen in the modern era you
know where you have to shoot the three
not just be able to handle the ball as
passing skills you know great great
young talent but I don't know if I would
tank for anyone ever you know just
because the uncertainty of how that
translates into the NBA is always a
gamble so shy on what's the what's the
gamble that of him that he cannot shoot
the three and what era where you've got
to do if he was it's funny because if he
was playing however I would be like oh
he's gonna be a superstar but the way
the game is played a noun that the
question would be is will they allow him
to do what he does well in the current
state of basketball of analytics and
because what he does well is really good
and you can do that in college
basketball they allowed the analytics
don't play because of a 40-minute game
it doesn't have the same translation but
in pro basketball they look
and they say no we're not taking those
shots we're not taking these type of
shots what is going I can t Smith here
on the Rich Eisen show I mean we're
seeing it right now with Hardin the run
that he's on right right where sometimes
it is just breathtaking watching him
play and then there are other times
he'll go 11 for 34 and still have a 37.9
and they lose right right so what what
what's the end game here do you think
with the combination of analytics and
talent in the NBA there's the Andal it's
also built on style of play and you know
so if you're playing a certain style
your analytics are gonna be skewed a
certain way so that's where coaching
comes in understanding that you could
okay let's say Sam Cassell that I play
with you know he's a coach of the
Clippers now assistant coach he could
make six out of ten in between shots
every time like if you gave we had games
if you looked at at 6 for 10 Sam of make
in between shots that's 12 points so you
say oh well we only have to make four
out of 10 to do that but the the the
mental mindset of a guy hitting six
shots on you as a defender mm-hmm you
know it takes breath out of you as well
so there's this things like that there's
foul trouble being able to you know so I
think there's gonna be a transcendent
player maybe Zion's a transcendent
player that he is so good in the
in-between and and laya game like Shaq
was in posting posting up that he
transcends and changes the analytics and
says no we could go back to throwing the
ball inside possibly we can go back to
taking these type of shots Kenny Smith
here on the Rich Eisen show just from
down the hall right here on the campus
Turner so do you have a prediction on
the Superbowl here in Atlanta man I live
in Los Angeles now you do I don't see
that many well know there's one in the
back right there in the back there in
the back there like is he's dressed in
the old got the old school so I think by
default I'm rooting for the rams okay I
just would hate to go live the rest
summer knowing that everyone's miserable
they lost I don't want to be in LA if
they're miserable
I don't want to be euphoric well
everyone you know if this if the
Patriots lose people in New England as
you know I think they bask and being
miserable Chris is one of those people
right over there you know that's fine
Los Angeles they lose a Super Bowl I
mean which literally be 24 to 48 hours
and then it's 75 and sunny and there's
million you know you could yeah I would
be on a beach upset I wouldn't be in the
snow
yeah you're shoveling snow so I'm like
oh we lost this time baby's 40 and oh my
goodness yeah yeah I think I think but I
still I'm rooting for the ramps you
think they can pull it off though what
do you think I'm rooting for the right
okay very good
I like that I like that is there an
equivalent to Brady in the history of
the NBA that you could think they've
obviously Jordan is one in terms of
rings but Jordan never lost the finals
right but somebody who just keeps
playing and it gets better with age is
there a is there an equivalent that
you'd come we're an era of this guy
LeBron James like the runners he's had
for the last 12 years you know you know
the obviously the rule changes have
helped him stay at the level that he's
at as well you know the no hand check
rule and you know that's why guys like
Vince Carter and nobody could play the
40 but yeah Kuzma horns not in the
middle of the lane gonna take your and
and you don't you're not slowed down at
any you you you never slowed down
there's you know if you watch an NBA
game now this would be the first time
that you'll see a god bring the
basketball up from baseline to
three-point line and no one touches them
I'm never like I watched the game and
I'm just an amazement because I still
have imprints of Derek Harper's hand
it's right on your head on my back right
you know from the Knicks series but in
the finals but I think LeBron James
would be that every year because these
rules allow you to be good Oh
in the NBA and you could still catch
stay consistent so he is the Tom Brady
of the enemy yeah I guess I'm wondering
if we could continue this analogy with
the rule changes in the NFL in a way
that you you can't hit a quarterback in
certain parts of question right but
Brady is also smart enough to get rid of
the ball
I mean he's LeBron doing anything that
you see that's extending his career I
know he's still hurt right now but you
think he's easy has he changed his style
of playing in a way that can help him
stay play longer he's the older you get
the longer your jump shot becomes if you
notice he shoots more threes now and
because of that you know you can get to
the rim but but it's much more difficult
at times when it is a half-court set his
jump shot has improved dramatically so
he will settle and take the three where
early in his career he wouldn't settle
for that he would he would attempt to
get to the rim and so his ability to
shoot the basketball has gotten better
and yeah and now I guess last one for
you here Kenny Smith do you buy into the
fact that Anthony Davis is agent same as
LeBron who LeBron is also an owner of
the agency has made these maneuvers
public to get ad to Los Angeles and then
all of a sudden Kyrie is is rumored to
be open to a reunion and klay Thompson
would be raising his hand saying I'm
coming in July if all this happens do
you buy into all that right now I would
say this if my brother was an agent for
the second best player in his position
or the best player in his position he
would be coming with me
there was no way I mean there it is
obvious that that is a part of a
possible plan now the ultimately his
allegiance is to what's best for Anthony
Davis you know rich Paul that's his
ultimate but what best for him is Los
Angeles that is best for him if he feels
that he can't win in New Orleans here's
a guy who's been to the fight
eight straight times he's somewhat
evened out he has he hasn't he hasn't
peaked mmm Pete he's not going down but
he's at the pinnacle and you're reaching
yours and so you can help him ride into
the sunset with four or five more
championships as an agent the best
opportunity may be that now the
differences will New Orleans be able to
pull off a deal now
or they gonna have to wait until he's a
free agent but the best situation for
Anthony Davis if you say play with
LeBron
it wouldn't be the goat it wouldn't be
to go to Boston and play with maybe
Kyrene gordon hayward join that team you
know knows guys been to the finals this
guy's been there mm-hmm
so the best scenarios with the guy was
bitten and you said you want to get to
the finals mmm you want to win an NBA
championship this is the modern-day Tom
Brady my guess Kyrie about there but he
had LeBron with him so he could be in
the Kyrie role going to Los Angeles and
you think Kyrie really is open to a
reunion with LeBron that I don't know I
don't know about that klay Thompson the
Kyrie Irving but when I when someone
publicly says I am I want to be out of
here mm-hm and publicly says it
the obvious place is Los Angeles without
question good we went so if we lose the
Super Bowl yes and we get a D we won't
be as bad on the beach or the folks at
New Orleans who thought they should have
been in the Superbowl
you know yeah that would be really bad
that would be the worst that's the
one-two punch to the gut good to see you
man robbed and robbed again come out
coming in Los Angeles to come in Los
Angeles studio again I know you've been
there before
let's have a race man me and you okay
let's do that let's do that I would love
to do that I raced Chris Webber I'll
race you well see Webb has a long stride
so not beat Chris well just let you know
you did yeah there's there's evidence
but there was some tricky trickery at so
I was beating him by so much I thought
he quit the race so I started putting my
hands up mm-hmm and I'm dancing around
and he'd ov he and he I turn around he's
right there he grabbed the tape oh it's
the reach she has read but no I was so I
was about from here from this distance
and then I just started like celebrating
these like and that's it so it's Monica
now is run through the tape very good at
the jet on TNT which is again the most
extensive coverage in home for the NBA
all-star game in Charlotte later on
that's now this month Wow amazing we're
now in this month month of February good
to see you Kenny's good to see we've got
some very nice party gift for Kenny
Smith it's we'll make sure it's the
right size and event penny Smith here on
the Rich Eisen show the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience